[Music]
in your mind you'll begin to relive a journey you
try to bring it all back in a single image you say
this was Central America and suddenly you remember
a country road in El Salvador the sound of a bell
fragments of memory fall into place a jungle
clearing in Honduras the face of an ancient God
bit by bit you remember in the
ruins of a city that had once
been Spain you spoke in whispers
in the highlands of Guatemala in
an Indian village you felt a sudden
pulse of life all at once you smiled
pieces of a puzzle isolated moments break through
the web of memory fall into place on an island
off the coast of Panama you felt that you had
gone back as far in time as men could go [Music]
as far back as you could go but you went further
at the very beginning there was jungle
a silent challenge a harvest of gold
now the jungles take this was once a world
shut off from the world six countries linked
by history hemmed in by nature until the
sound of a motor cut through the jungle
[Music] the sound of a pioneer breaking new
ground [Music] the grouper that brought you
was once a year the zone that motor uses of
everyday sound blinking six borders south
of Mexico joining six countries with a single
word in the needle welcome welcome to Guatemala
dilma needle welcome to El Salvador you
heard it in Honduras bienvenido you
heard it in the car aqua in Costa Rica a
single word of greeting bienvenido
welcome to Panama [Music]
in your mind you relive a journey your
thoughts go back you remember Panama a
marketplace at the point where two continents
and two oceans meet perhaps it was Balboa who
dreamed it first dreamed of cutting through
the narrow strip of land joining water to water
at the start of our own century
the waters were joined [Music]
a crossroad